so the first major component we're going
to dive into to help is the html5
application cache this lets you provide
a local cache of html files css
javascript
images any other resources your client
web app may use and get the browser to
use them even before it tries to hit the
network
so let's take a look at how this works
and how we can use it the application
cache is a manifest that you point to
from inside your html element
let's take a look at the cache manifest
for our conference application the
manifest starts with the magic header
cache manifest lines that start with a
hash sign are actually comments
typically the second line is a comment
with some kind of cached version string
more on that later
but this is followed by a cache section
now what do you think goes in the cache
section should it be every file that's
on the server's file system
every resource that can be statically
served
or should it be a collection of cat
videos